you guys have both talked about how you
don't see your characters getting a
happy ending but are you happy with the
ending of the series and where your
character's stories conclude uh i don't
think happy's the right word no it's
i i think it's
right
you know it is what it what what it is
you know what i mean and we i feel
came at it as truthfully as possible
but i think i i don't really care about
happy
you know what i mean i and i think that
also the show has never really cared
about happy
it's it's it's it's to remain complex
and remain slightly in a place of
longing
i think i think that does yeah i would
agree it's because it's so different
when you're in it you know you just have
to focus on the kind of material and
what's up at hand and execute that and
then
like i feel like it's not until now and
people are asking us this question it's
like oh my god no people are gonna be
happy or they're gonna be mad or they're
gonna you know it's like
um because everyone's so invested in it
so i really hope that people
enjoy it you know and can see that the
characters got to a place and
you know because it led them there
truthfully
did either or both of you guys go into
shooting this season knowing what the
ending of the season would be
did you have
that information
no we like yes and no but no
like we knew vague details and where we
they were thinking of maybe
ending off but
it evolved as we were going you know a
lot of the time we kind of
we get the next episode when we're
filming you know we've got episode three
when we're filming two or you know
you're constantly kind of working at
that kind of pace so
a lot of those discussions were
happening when we were
um shooting i think our show in
particular in the scene this
season in particular we were really uh
uh
we were really discovering it and
creating it and making it
uh
while we were shooting it and accepting
it yeah yeah accepting it while we're
shooting it yeah you've had different
female voices for each of the four
seasons of this show
what has it been like to collaborate
with these incredibly talented women and
what do you feel laura neal brought to
this final season i think what you know
kind of said gentle have opened up here
is such an incredible opportunity you
know to give
um
like a a female writer this role each
season and kind of
delve in in that way and have them take
the lead um i think we've all learned so
much from it because each writer has
such a distinct voice and their own
impressions of the characters and where
they see the characters going that you
know you all end up having to kind of
mold to each other in a way and work
with each other
i think what i've really enjoyed about
it is this um
[Music]
it's been really inclusive in a sense of
like we all get around the table and we
discuss and we chat about what it is
that is on the page and what feels right
i mean what doesn't feel right and
it's been always such an open
conversation i remember laura wrote you
know she wrote the last two episodes of
season three and
it was one of my favorite scenes with um
helene you know when she just got back
from russia with with her mom
um and i remember there was just a kind
of like freshness from laura and
um
i felt like she understood it and so to
be able to kind of carry that
relationship on with her was
um was amazing
sandra how has that been for you i mean
as an ep on the show
what's it been like to sort of refined
your voice among a different voice every
time
uh i found it really challenging
it's really challenging but within that
challenge and
in trying to adapt to new dynamics
uh
creativity can occur
you know it really can and so i really
much uh leaned into that yeah you know
it does it the the more the newer voices
you have
it just creates uh different dynamics
and sometimes it forces you to figure
out
uh
it forces you to think outside what you
think that the character is and
sometimes it really really forces you to
know even more of what the character is
because
you know throughout the whole four
seasons the consistency has been in the
cast yeah
and some of the crew members
and some of the crew members so
i i leaned into that while
you know welcoming that um
[Music]
fresh
and uh very different dynamics
jody why is it so important for
villanelle to
prove that she's different and that
she's changed do you feel like she can
really change is she just
past actually being able to do that why
is it so important for her this season
it's funny because i think on the
surface she feels it's important like i
feel like she
she thinks she's invincible and she can
put her hand to everything and she's
good at everything you know and then
to be told over and over again you know
especially by like her mom that she's
not worth anything she's bad she's
always been bad
monster like i think all these words
have kind of clung to her
and she sees that as a
a challenge and also like
i think there's part of her that wants
this other life is that once
um
you know is seeking this kind of
um
normal life it's not really a normal
life but you know she wants all these
things that she can't have because she's
a roamless enemy and and she finds that
in the church
you know i think she's tried and tried
and tried but she finds it in the church
and you know because we see um the
religion is representing something good
and she thinks if i you know i'm here
and i and i follow the rules and i do as
i'm told and i you know i stick to this
a b and c i am good and i've i've you
know
i've succeeded in that but i don't think
it's coming from an honest place
you know i don't i don't think she knows
who she is entirely um
and that's why this is a real challenge
for her because
um i don't think she can
escape herself
um
but she's trying
he's trying
santa
eve is on a revenge mission this season
which also seems to line up with what
carolyn has focused on what can you say
to tease what we can
expect from this mission and
tying in everything with the 12 i mean
how how far is all of this going to push
her to the edge
oh i think
eve goes on a
real existential journey
this season
uh
where
her search and hunt for the 12
pushes her towards i think and i also
feel quite deeply affected because of
the pandemic
the big questions of what is
what is like the meaning of life and the
purpose of being and
[Music]
how do you go on if nothing really
changes
um
which comes later on in the season
where i think that she's just left with
the big questions in life like how how
does one go on
i don't want good giving away there no
uh
but i it is it is a real existential
journey
and and it goes quite dark for she she
hits the she hits those limits
yeah it seems like she's more willing to
take
more drastic steps to get what she wants
yes does that feel further away from who
she's been until now or does it feel
closer to who she's becoming
oh
deeper absolutely into who she is
you know you
to be able to explore i mean obviously
fictitiously through a character your
own moral ambiguity
you you know to me and to not deny that
i like the fact that this
this season you see eve kind of embrace
it and step into it wholeheartedly it
takes her into like very questioning
places but there's uh less fear i'd say
there's less fear or there's less
unwillingness there's more confidence
within just just stepping into that
which clearly i think just
just makes her a more whole character
where do these characters fit into each
other's lives at this point because they
are taking very different personal
journeys so how is that changing how
they
feel about each other
i don't know if it really changes how
they feel about each other i think
there's
i think i can say for eve there is
less denial
of who villanelle
not so much is or but is to her
right so
i think uh you see how much more deeply
villanelle has affected eve i see
i see the change in eve from the top of
the series to then deeper into the
series you
um and because you do spend more time
with the both of them
um
it's just a new way of seeing how
they've affected each other and how they
affect each other yeah
even even though there's a lot going on
there just seems to be like a
a calmness like less resistance between
the two
it feels like we've we've earned this
given everywhere we've been beforehand
like it's come to this natural place of
we're now seeing them yeah you just
see them reacting in ways that are so
different because it's all it's in the
past has been so hostile and
um
kind of fragmented that
it feels very different this season
from the bridge you know from the bridge
onwards yeah
i appreciate you both talking to me
about this it has been so fantastic to
watch you both in these characters and i
can't wait to see the rest of the season
i hope you enjoy it thank you so much